pire dominique baudis je remercie les
membres de la commission des lois qui
sont venus nombreux et les membres des
autres commissions qui ont bien voulu
nous rejoindre et qui manifeste du fait
que le sujet dont nous allons parler
l'intéressent véritablement l'ensemble
du sénat monsieur dominique baudis
vous savez qu'il y a eu il compris au
sénat quelques débats sur la création du
défenseur des droits
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous dire
publiquement lors d'une précédente de
vaud venu ici que la vigueur avec
laquelle avec vos équipes
vous accomplissez votre mission montre
que ce qui avait pu émettre un certain
nombre d'interrogations sur le bien
fondé de votre structure de cette
nouvelle structure sont amenés à
constater le travail qui est fait dans
de nombreux domaines qui intéressent la
vie de nos concitoyens
vous avez fait un rapport qui a suscité
beaucoup d'intérêt
beaucoup d'attention sur une double
question puisqu'il y a deux titres au
rapport le premier c'est le plus large
les rapports entre la police et les
citoyens
et le fuji l'autre titre c'est les
contrôles d'identité
il est tout à fait clair qu'il s'agit de
sujets très importants
nous sommes tous attachés et je pense
pouvoir parler au nom de tous les
collègues à aux citoyens fonctionnaires
et militaires qui assument les missions
de la police et de la gendarmerie et se
préoccupe de la sécurité dans notre pays
c'est leur mission elle est difficile
nous sommes aussi très attentifs à la
situation dans nos quartiers à la
situation de notre jeunesse et au fait
finalement que les relations qui
existent entre ceux qui ont mission
celles et ceux qui ont mission d'assurer
ses tâches de sécurité et l'ensemble des
citoyens y compris ceux à qui on demande
l'identité se passe dans de bonnes
conditions
dans des conditions propres à assurer
une confiance confiance dans
l'institution républicaine et c'est
pourquoi cette question est importante
des propositions ont été faites
des annonces ont été faites et chacun
les connaît euh vous avez eu souhaité
prendre le problème dans toute son
ampleur procéder à beaucoup d' analyse
eux allés voir les exemples étrangers de
manière à faire un rapport qui est dense
et permet d'appréhender la question avec
un maximum d'informations donc je vais
vous proposer mes chers collègues
d'abord d'écouter monsieur le défenseur
des droits et puis je veux je vous
donnerai la parole pour que vous
puissiez poser toutes les questions et
dans une dernière partie
je donnerai la parole à madame
virginie klès qui est rapporteur du
budget du défenseur des droits
et qui à ce titre aura quelques
questions à lui poser donc merci encore
usher dominique baudis d'être venus eux
et je vous donne tout de suite la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames messieurs merci
tout d'abord monsieur le président de
votre habitation
merci mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de votre présence cette
audition qui va me donner l'occasion de
vous présenter les grandes lignes d'un
rapport que l'institution du défenseur
des droits a publié tout récemment et
qui porte comme le président jean pierre
sueur vient de le rappeler sur les
relations police population et plus
spécifiquement la question des contrôles
d'identité
la question des relations police
population
c'est un débat que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les démocraties et je dirais que
c'est même un signe de vitalité
démocratique et qu'il ne faut pas s'en
inquiéter ou y voir le signe d'une crise
il n'y a que dans les sociétés
totalitaires où il n'y a pas de débat
autour des relations police population
mais selon les payer sont les périodes
ce débat relations police population se
cristallise sur différents sujets en
france depuis un bon nombre d'années
c'est la question des contrôles
d'identité qui a cristallisé la
controverse
le débat sur les contrôles d'identité
est un débat très très anciens fin des
années 70 début des années 80 la loi
sécurité et liberté mais aujourd'hui on
le voit bien ce n'est pas le principe
même du contrôle d'identité qui fait
débat mais plutôt la façon dont ils
s'exercent et le sentiment éprouvé par
de nombreux citoyens est exprimée par de
nombreuses associations sentiment que
ces contrôles ciblerait plus
particulièrement certains publics
tout d'abord les personnes d'origine non
européenne
deuxièmement les plus jeunes
et troisièmement ceux qui par leur tenue
vestimentaire
voilà ne relève pas 10 ans du format
conventionnel dans le sentiment quand on
est jeune issu de l'immigration est
habillé avec un sweat à capuche
ben on a quinze ou vingt fois plus de
risques d'être contrôlées que si on est
blanc qu'on ait qu'un cas génère et
comporte aucune crainte
alors ces sujets sont emportés vous le
savez bien par beaucoup d'associations
que j'ai rencontrés dans les mois qui
ont suivi mon entrée en fonction comme
défenseur des droits au mois de juin
diverses associations dont certaines
sont très engagés sur ce sujet human
rights watch en particulier mais amnesty
international sos racisme et différentes
associations donc au mois de janvier
dernier
j'ai pris la décision d'engager un
travail de réflexion d'étude avec le
concours de mon adjointe chargé de la
déontologie de la sécurité madame motte
et évidemment du secrétaire général
richard senghor qui est à ma droite donc
deux mois 2
février dernier jusqu'au mois d'octobre
nous avons travaillé sur ce sujet alors
d'abord en entendant les parties
concernées par le débat les associations
qui soulève cette question
les syndicats de policiers
la direction générale de la gendarmerie
et puis nous allons participer à toute
une série de réunions dont certaines ont
eu lieu d'ailleurs dans les murs du
sénat à l'initiative de votre collègue
madame benbassa j'ai rencontré plusieurs
parlementaires soit président de groupe
soit président de commission
j'ai rencontré des parlementaires
intéressés par ce sujet comme le
sénateur pozzo di borgo qui vient de
déposer une proposition il ya quelques
semaines sur ce sujet comme madame
benbassa l'avait fait au début de
l'année où à la fin de l'année
précédente
et enfin nous sommes allés dans
différents pays qui était donné en
exemple cité en exemple par les
associations pays où le contrôle
d'identité se déroule dans le cas d'une
procédure à l'occasion de laquelle la
personne contrôlée se voir remettre par
le contrôleur un document alors ce qu'on
a appelé communément récépissé que je
passais rappelait d'ailleurs plutôt
attestation que récépissé parce que
c'est pas le reçu par rapport à quelque
chose dont nous sommes allés dans ces
pays
nous avons rencontré bien sûr les
autorités de police les associations les
responsables politiques locaux et et
nous avons conclu
ce travail de réflexion par un colloque
qui a eu au début du mois d'octobre à
paris réunissant les parlementaires qui
ont voulu y assister les responsables de
police des pays où un système tel s'est
développé et les représentants des
associations avant de publier donc ce ce
rapport alors le rapport dresse un état
des lieux
il rend compte de toutes les auditions
et il reprend il exposé les arguments
des uns et des autres en faveur ou au
contraire à l'encontre d'une solution de
remise d'un document
nous analysons les expériences à
l'étranger en espagne dans une ville en
fête fuenlabrada qui est une ville de 20
à 25 mille habitants dans la banlieue de
madrid
jusqu'à présent l'expérimentation de
fuenlabrada n'a pas été étendu à
d'autres villes
en revanche en grande bretagne à londres
en particulier
de même que dans certaines villes
américaines en particulier new york et
dans certaines villes canadiennes
il ya là un dispositif installé depuis
déjà un certain temps dont on peut par
conséquent mesurer les résultats alors
les conclusions que l'on peut tirer des
des expériences enfin plus que les
expériences des pratiques dans ces pays
anglo saxons montre que la délivrance
d'un document à l'occasion du contrôle
d'identité a pour effet mécaniquement de
faire diminuer le nombre de contrôles ne
serait ce que parce que c'est d'ailleurs
un des arguments soulevés par les
syndicats de fonctionnaires de police tu
ne serait ce que parce que l'opération
de contrôle et plus longue puisqu'elle
s'accompagne de du renseignement de d'un
document donc diminution du nombre de
contrôles
en revanche il apparaît que le débat sur
le caractère ou non discriminatoire de
ces contrôles ce qui est un ciblage au
faciès le débat dans les pays où le
système est développée ne s'est pas état
d'une certaine manière
d'ailleurs le débat n'en est que plus
vif parce que aujourd'hui dans notre
pays où le contrôle ne laisse pas de
trace sauf si une infraction qui a des
suites contrôler un contrôle ne laissant
pas de traces on à l'expression de
ressenti de la part des associations
comme de la part des syndicats de
fonctionnaires de police ou de
militaires de gendarmerie en revanche
dans les pays où existent ce type de
dispositif des chiffres viennent
éclairer le débat en quelque sorte on
n'est plus là sur du ressenti
mais sur des chiffres puisque dans ces
pays là le document qui est établie
indique l'appartenance ethnique ou
raciale
de la personne contrôlée à tel ou tel
groupe se sont souvent d'ailleurs les
personnes elles-mêmes qui choisissent le
groupe dans lequel elle souhaite que le
contrôleur les arrange noir d'eau
pakistanais asiatiques et c'est donc le
nombre de contrôles diminue le débat sur
le caractère discriminatoire du contrôle
ne s'éteint pas troisième élément
ces dispositifs sont évidemment
intransposable dans notre pays puisqu'il
faudrait en fait réviser la constitution
et rentrer dans un système totalement
étranger à notre système républicain
c'est-à-dire catégoriser les personnes
en fonction de leur appartenance à tel
ou tel groupe ethnique ou racial dont
l'expérience était intéressante à
analyser
elle est instructive et en même temps il
faut bien être conscient du fait qu'elle
n'est pas transposable en tant que tel
dans notre pays alors ces constats et en
est en fait la troisième partie du
rapport que nous avons intitulé
perspectives nous permet de formuler des
propositions à l'attention des pouvoirs
publics parlement gouvernement
alors ces propositions la première
concerne l'identification des
fonctionnaires de police qui n'est pas
lié d'ailleurs simplement à la question
des contrôles d'identité qui est liée à
la relation entre la police et la
population et plus globalement
d'ailleurs entre la population les
citoyens et les fonctionnaires une loi
de 2003 indique que tout fonctionnaire
doit être identifiable par le citoyen
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
identifiable pas nécessairement par son
nom et s'agissant de forces de sécurité
évidemment il ne peut pas s'agir du non
mais
d'un numéro de matricule de numéro
professionnel que les fonctionnaires de
police ont d'ailleurs longtemps porté de
manière visible sur leur uniforme
jusqu'en 1984 85 à l'occasion de la mise
en service d'un nouvel uniforme pour les
fonctionnaires de police
le matricule a disparu et l'étude à la
fois des arrêts de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme des prises de
position du conseil de l'europe du
commissaire européen aux droits de
l'homme montre bien que voilà toutes ses
instances internationales chargées de
veiller au respect des droits de l'homme
indique à quel point il est nécessaire
que dans une société démocratique
le fonctionnaire de police dans
l'exercice de son activité puisse être
identifiables par le citoyen de façon à
pouvoir fonder un éventuel recours donc
un simplement sur la relation autour du
contrôle d'identité et de son caractère
éventuellement discriminatoire
globalement il nous paraît nécessaire
que le fonctionnaire de police puissent
être identifiés dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions et nous préconisons donc le
rétablissement du matricule
le deuxième élément qui est apparu à
l'occasion des auditions en particulier
à l'occasion du débat organisé par
madame benbassa il y a quelques mois ici
au sénat
c'est la question des palpations de
sécurité il apparaît que très souvent
ces contrôles sa compagne de palpation
de sécurité qui ne sont aucunement
encadré ni par le code de procédure
pénale ni par le code de déontologie
de la police ou la charte de la
gendarmerie et les entretiens avec les
fonctionnaires de police ont clairement
fait apparaître que c'est laissé à
l'appréciation du policier sur le
terrain et les uns et les autres avaient
des visions assez différente les zones
où dix ans bah oui on commence par ça
parce que c'est une question de sécurité
sécurité pour les passants autour qui
parfois voilà se tiennent à proximité de
la personne contrôlée sécurité pour la
personne contrôlée sécurité évidemment
pour le fonctionnaire de police donc on
commence par s'assurer que la personne
ne porte pas de couteau une arme dont on
commence par la palpation d'autres
fonctionnaires d'autres syndicats nous
disons non ça ne doit pas être
systématique
il faut aussi procéder lorsque on estime
que c'est absolument nécessaire et enfin
les gendarmes de leur côté là ce sont
pas les syndicats puisque à peine
syndicales et la direction générale ont
dit les palpations de sécurité nous nous
procédons que de manière très
exceptionnelle
et lorsque nous jugeons que c'est
indispensable dont il apparaît qu'il ya
des pratiques très différentes et
qu'elles sont entièrement laissée à
l'appréciation des personnels sur le
terrain et nous en concluons donc qui
serait nécessaire d'introduire dans le
code de procédure pénale et dans le code
de déontologie de la police nationale
qui à l'heure actuelle est en phase de
réécriture des dispositions qui à la
fois encadre les palpations de sécurité
et leur donne une véritable base
juridique
troisième point dans les perspectives
la question de la délivrance d'un
document d'une attestation
alors je répète que évidemment les
solutions anglo saxon ne sont pas
transposables en l'état puisqu'elle
classe les personnes en fonction de
groupes ethniques ou raciaux néanmoins
on peut tout à fait imaginer en france
des dispositifs qui à droit constant
introduire et cette procédure de
délivrance d'un document à l'occasion
d'un contrôle
ce que nous disons avant d'examiner les
différentes solutions possibles
c'est que tout dispositif doit être
préalablement expérimenté sur un
territoire
il apparaît que dans les pays où on a
voulu du jour au lendemain
généraliser un dispositif nouveau sens
qu'il est été testé expérimenté pendant
plusieurs mois sur un territoire donné
se sont soldées par des échecs
donc l'expérimentation nous paraît la
condition préalable indispensable mais
il y à des responsables et des élus des
collectivités locales qui ont fait
connaître leur désir d'être territoire
d'expérimentation différentes communes
à commencer par la plus importante de
toute la ville de paris qui a voté un
voeu souhaitant être territoire
d'expérimentation pour des mesures
encadrant ou régulant les contrôles
d'identité dont expérimentation alors
quels dispositifs sont envisageables il
se range en trois en trois catégories
on va partir du dispositif le plus léger
jusqu au dispositif le plus le plus
lourd
le dispositif le plus léger c'est ce
qu'on a appelé la remise d'un ticket de
contrôle
anonyme c'est à dire que le contrôleur
demande les papiers à personne contrôlée
mais vous avec en échange contrepartie
le contrôleur mais à la personne
contrôlée ticket de contrôle sur lequel
figure le matricule du contrôleur c'est
à dire que c'est la même philosophie que
le matricule visible mais voilà
matricule visible sortir un stylo noter
là
contrôleur donne un papier sans que le
contrôler et à lui demander votre
matricule je voudrais voir laissez moi
noté le contrôle et repart avec le
numéro matricule et l'unité à laquelle
appartient le contrôleur alors
l'avantagent de ce dispositif c'est que
c'est très rapide ça ne sorte pas à
l'objection souvent formulées par les
policiers on va perdre du temps c'est
très rapide en arrache un ticket et on
le donne ça rétabli une sorte d'égalité
entre le contrôleur et le contrôlé forme
de geste de courtoisie
je vous demande qui vous êtes et je vous
dis qui je suis première solution
deuxième solution
l'attestation nominatives le contrôleur
revient à la personne contrôlée une
attestation mais que le contrôleur va
devoir remplir
parce que va figurer sur cette
association le nom de la personne
contrôlée
le lieu la date et l'heure du contrôle
éventuellement le motif alors évidemment
dans cette hypothèse le document détenu
par la personne contrôlée à une valeur
programme plus importante parce que
quand c'est simplement le ticket de
contrôle anonyme
on peut se les repasser on peut les
collectionner là c'est nominatif donc
dans l'hypothèse d'un recours introduit
par la personne contrôlée soit auprès
d'une juridiction administrative soit
auprès du défenseur des droits au titre
de la déontologie de la sécurité sont
auprès d'une inspection générale il ya
un preuve que cette personne a été
contrôlé et si effectivement ce sont des
contrôles à répétition a fortiori s'ils
sont des contrôles à répétition par les
mêmes fonctionnaires il est certain que
voilà ça permet d'étayer une démarche de
recours mais dans cette hypothèse
seul le contrôle et conserve les
éléments l'attestation le contrôleur lui
ne conserve rien troisième catégorie de
solutions
délivrance d'une attestation nominatives
mais avec un double qui va être conservé
par le contrôleur par le policier avec
la deux options une option double
anonymisées c'est la solution de la
proposition de loi de m bemba ça et
aussi je crois celle yves pozzo di borgo
dire que nos policiers concerne le
double mais il n'y a pas le nom de la
personne contrôlée
il ya le lieu la date le motif donc ça
permet d'avoir une évaluation
statistique de l'activité de la police
néanmoins il s'agit de la création d'un
fichier même si les pas de caractère
nominatif avec tout le problème qui va
conserver ce fichier à quelles fins pour
quelle durée etc et enfin dernière
solution
l'attestation de contrôle avec un double
mais un double non pas anonymisées avec
le double également nominatif
ce qui veut dire que le policier va
conserver le nom de celui qui a été
contrôlée l'heure le lieu la date le
motif et sait se pose avec plus encore
d'acuité les questions même question
précédemment
il y aura un fichier il y aurait
fichiers nominatifs
il ya des centaines de milliers de noms
qui vont se retrouver dans ce fichier
est ce que ce dispositif va pas être
considérés par les citoyens comme un
dispositif liberticide puisqu'au fond la
police va conserver en mémoire dans ses
ordinateurs à des centaines de milliers
de données qui permettront de retracer
les déplacements d à d autres et à forte
à parier que dans le cadre par exemple
d'une enquête de police judiciaire sur
un cri ou sur un délit grave
les enquêteurs rancourt ont à ce fichier
pour essayer de procéder à des
recoupements donc ce dispositif
comportant le nom c'est un dispositif
effectivement qui va retracer très
exactement toutes les situations mais
qui peut être ressenti dans les citoyens
comme quelque chose d'excessif est au
fond un dispositif destiné à protéger
les droits des citoyens risque d'être
perçue par les citoyens comme dispositif
mettant en cause leur droit individuel
voilà les différentes options que nous
avons identifié et entendu je le répète
qu' aucune option à mon avis ne peut
être retenue globalement sans avoir été
préalablement expertise et surin est
plutôt plusieurs territoires pendant une
période de plusieurs mois
et enfin un dernier élément sont les
éléments de conclusion il nous est
apparu au fil des auditions policiers et
associations que nous manquions
cruellement de lieu de dialogue
permanent entre les associations et les
forces de sécurité
j'ai indiqué dans le rapport que notre
institution est évidemment disponible
pour participer
d'abord aux cycles de formation initiale
et continue des fonctionnaires de police
que nous pouvons également contribuer à
créer une sorte de lieu de dialogue
permanent entre les policiers et les
associations parce que en les entendant
séparément j'ai pu mesurer à quel point
il y avait de part et d'autre des des
fantasmes des procès d'intention d'une
méconnaissance des motifs qui anime
l'autre voilà donc il nous paraît
nécessaire sur le plan national et aussi
sur le plan local dans le cas des
comités locaux de disait avant
prévention de la délinquance plus
comment on l'appelle matin comment voilà
ça nous paraît également nécessaire de
rechercher localement et nationalement
des lieux de dialogue et des échanges
entre forces de sécurité et associations
voilà je vous ai résumé à grands traits
le rapport bon qui est qui l'aurait
conséquente que on en a quelques
exemplaires d'accord on a deux exemples
de toute façon il est sur le site
internet du défenseur des droits dont
vous pouvez demander à vos
collaborateurs de vous le téléchargez et
vous pourrez voilà à voir ce travail
complet dans lequel évidemment nous
mentionnons et nous analysons les
propositions de lois deux de vos
collègues qui ont été déposées sur le
bureau du sénat
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs ce que je
voulais vous dire pour introduire le
débat la discussion à je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions en compagnie de richard
senghor qui est le secrétaire général du
défenseur des droits
ma compagne avant luc machard t-il le
directeur général de services richard
senghor s'occupe de la production
juridique et et luc machard s'occupe du
fonctionnement et de l'organisation de 7
institution nouvelle un accompagnement
au directeur de cabinet antoine réseau
et audrey kaiser qui est chargé des
relations avec les parlementaires et les
i merci monsieur le dire merci monsieur
le défenseur des droits de pour cet
exposé qui comme à l'accoutumée de votre
part et très pédagogique et précis et
c'est très important je pense pour nous
pour ceux qui nous écouteront alors mes
chers collègues qui souhaitent
intervenir
donc alors il ya monsieur pozzo di borgo
madame benbassa alors madame benbassa
monsieur le comte
monsieur le chef monsieur van dieren
donc monsieur béchu monsieur gorce
madame vous voulez monsieur monsieur
boyer ce que je moi monsieur voyez rien
alors liste des orateurs inscrits
monsieur pozzo di borgo madame benbassa
monsieur le comte monsieur lecerf
monsieur van d'irène donc monsieur béchu
monsieur gorce madame boulet monsieur
boyer il n'y a pas de remords il
pourrait y avoir de remords tardifs
alors monsieur pozzo di borgo oui
monsieur le président merci d'avoir deux
invités puisque je suis quand la
commission des lois a serré que je suis
élu du 7e arrondissement c'est peut-être
de l'arrondissement le plus conservateur
de paris pub de france
c'est vrai que c'est apparemment des
problèmes qu'on rencontre au pas ce
genre de sous les contrôles d'identité
mais il faut savoir que dans le 7e
arrondissement nous avons la moitié des
manifestations de paris veut dire sur
les 3000 à 4000 manifestation qui a
chacun à paris la moitié en lui restait
à maron doucement et je suis élu depuis
de nombreuses années seront 10 mans et
c'est vrai qu'à souvent eu des problèmes
de tension d'agressivité de la part d'un
police à l'égard des habitants parce que
c'est pas simple mais il policier n'est
pas simple c'est un métier d'adrénaline
quand vous avez à gérer une
manifestation et c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas monsieur que j'étais assez
à la suite de ça j'ai pas différentes
raisons j'ai rencontré des associations
qui défendent elles eu ce problème de
récépissé alors évidemment ce n'était
pas un thème ni le droit d'y du centre
niveau des rues de paris plutôt une
majorité faire d'opposition dans un
quartier très traditionnelle mais je me
suis quand même rendu compte que quand
on prend les chiffres de l'observatoire
national de la délinquance entre 1996 et
2007 des outrages à agents sont passés
17000 à 31000 ce qui veut dire
manifestement sans compter non plus les
trop nombreuses agressions physiques
dont sont victimes des forces de l'ordre
ça veut dire si les cas véritablement un
problème de confiance entre les forces
de l'ordre et puis les citoyens qu'elle
contrôle vous savez également je crois
que dominique baudis le défenseur et
drôle à duingt la cité le rapport du
cnrs et du centre de recherches
sociologiques sur le droit et les
institutions pénales rejoint par la
structure human watch constate que quand
vous êtes jeunes vous êtes contrôlés on
soit plus que lorsque vous êtes commises
et le défenseur des droits sexagénaire
aux quinquagénaires avec cravate comme
nous quand vous êtes noir vous être
contre et six fois plus est lorsque la
d'origine et nick arabe être contrôlés
en huit fois plus alors c'est vrai qu'il
y avait un problème je pense de
relations entre la police et puis le
problème de la génération plutôt jeune
et de te des gens qui sont c'est à dire
le contrôle au faciès gsi d'un peu de
travailler dessus notamment j'essaie de
travailler dans la logique de la défense
la police si je considère que la prise
de pu être crédible à l'égard de alors
ils y apprennent plus générale je crois
que la suppression de la prise de
proximité a été un des éléments
accélérateur de ses débuts dès jeudi
ces attaques ont de la place sera prise
de vue aussi milité pour mon accident à
hauteur de ces éléments de
dysfonctionnements sur les contrôles
d'identité
ça je crois que pour les problèmes
deuxième problème avant de
j'ai écouté plusieurs phases
associations qui sont une voire
plusieurs fois mais avant de me lancer
là dedans j'ai posé la question à des
policiers a dit policiers carrément voir
les policiers qui sont devant le sénat
les policiers je rencontre et que je
suis parlementaire soin de réfléchir sur
le récépissé jan poser la question et
tous curieusement m'ont répondu mais
nous on n'est pas content contraire la
seule chose on veut pas et ça a été le
dossier mal parti après l'élection du
président hollande quand je crois les
jeunes socialistes ont fait courir le
bruit que le nombre de la suppliciée
devait être limitée à 2 ou 3 et des
mines on veut pas que les délinquants
puissent dire on est contre et trois
fois pour puis ce fut les contrôles et
je sais pas si vous soucier de ça il est
très surpris que sur les vingt ou trente
policiers que j'ai rencontré une femme
il était très surprise avec comme
communication ce dossier que la
communication qui avait été fait parler
je crois les jeunes socialistes en
disant il faut qu'elle s'adonne de
récépissé qui sonnait pas police une
fois que la pluie ça qu'on prenait
quelqu'un trois fois le contrôle plus et
ça ça va ça a donné une image négative
soit fait de récépissé même temps tous
musée mais n'ont aucun problème aux
nuits demandeur est ce la raison pour
laquelle si vous voulez moi j'ai déposé
deux propositions de loi en concertation
avec les associations mais vous
souhaitez que le contrôle des associés
avec le contrôle de ces listes que le
contrôle de ces de c2c contrôle
identitaire fait que le que le firent le
parrainage c'est notre identité se fasse
par une structure à part je suis moi
même inspecteur général administration
éducation nationale d'art cherche donc à
ventilateur j'avais ça et j'avais moi
même comme sous mon autorité à l'époque
j'étais le référent spécialiste des
problèmes d'hygiène sécurité de tout le
système et d'universitaires éducatif
pour ce concert primaire yacht c'est un
truc et non mais on avait la
responsabilité ces inspections qui avait
la responsabilité et je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas utiliser des inspections
de la d'émissaires de l'intérieur pour
être pour parrainer ce genre de
supervision du contrôle d'identité parce
que je considère et j'ai souvent parlé à
soi les préfectures rencontré quand il
venait d'arriver à paris soit des
commissaires de police qu'ils ont
souhaité rhin je vais souvent parlé de
ce problème là et moi je considère que
ce dérapage qui peut y avoir soin par
les bac locale soit par la police vient
très souvent de la hiérarchie et moi
dans le proposition de loi que j'ai fait
pour ceux qui occupent plus intéressé je
souhaite que ce soit la hiérarchie
policière elle même qui prend en compte
ce problème là et c'est pour ça que je
souhaitais que ce soit à l'inspection
générale
shihri gs qui supervise voilà les
quelques éléments que j'ai oublié sachez
aussi vous conseiller de paris nous
avons eu un débat assez large à dessus
c'était un amendement je crois ou veux
du groupe communiste qui a été votée par
les socialistes les verts et puis par le
groupe centriste que je te le présenter
comme centre ici nous avons voté ce voeu
pour que paris devienne une propose un
parti moment il ya un texte de loi soit
un élément d'expérimentation de ce
dossier voilà merci de m'avoir écouté
merci monsieur pozzo di borgo madame
benbassa monsieur baudis je vous
remercie pour cette conférence à
laquelle je suis arrivé un peu en retard
j'avais une réunion
excusez moi mais vous savez que je vous
suis je viens souvent assez souvent vous
voir je vous félicite ainsi que votre
équipe pour le rapport que vous avez
fait est que j'ai lu et que je trouve
très proches de ceux qui ont entendu
ensemble vous vous avez entendu d'autres
personnes mais tout au moins les
personnes que nous avons entendus
ensemble
vous avez su livrer leur point de vue et
faire une synthèse avec tout cela et
j'ai plusieurs questions mais une qui me
préoccupe le plus c'est celle de
l'attitude de la police lorsque nous
étions au colloque que vous avez
organisé vous avez bien vu d'ailleurs
une des possibilités que vous nous
présentez c'est ce fameux ticket
l'espace est quasiment les matricules à
sion qu'on donnerait c'était la police
américaine n'est ce pas qui disait
qu'elle donnait une carte de visite aux
personnes contrôle si mon souvenir est
bon bon c'est une des possibilités mais
lorsque nous avons entendu chez vous la
police et ont peut-être on a invité que
les personnes très concerné tout au
moins et la police aussi bien américaine
anglais
koech espagnol qui allaient qui fait des
expérimentations n'est ce pas dans les
banlieue de madrid se montraient tout à
fait favorable à ces à ce contrôle ne
sont pas pleins outre mesure ils nous
ont donné leurs possibilités et la façon
dont ils menaient leur leur contrôle
et ce qui ce qui ressort de ce que j'ai
entendu par rapport aux auditions que
j'ai pu avec beaucoup de peine faire
avec quelques syndicats de police
c'est quasiment le contraire qui se
passe est une opposition frontale à ce
récépissé récépissé au ticket à l'époque
j'avais papa les tickets chez les bucks
à exister mais bon elle le récépissé
alors est-ce que les gens que vous avez
reçu vous ce sont des personnes va les
espagnols je les ai reçus aussi cesser
ces personnes ces policiers est ce que
disons ils ont tu déjà une formation
importante qui fait qu'ils ne voient pas
ce contrôle qu'il ne considère pas ce
contrôle comme une atteinte à leur
propre pouvoir tandis que ce qui ressort
des des auditions des syndicats de
police et ils prennent ça comme si
c'était une façon de le voir à la baisse
leurs pouvoirs et à côté de ça on entend
un disque où l'on a été récemment à
cette je sais pas vous n'y étiez pas je
crois il y a eu une soirée ô mon
collègue est venue également de
l'association stop aux contrôles au
faciès et nous ont montré quelques enfin
ils ont fait quelques films c'est la
deuxième saison je crois et dans ses
films ce qui ressort ce c7 cette hargne
des personnes contrôlées l'humiliation
qu'elle ressente la façon de dettes
contrôler
qu'ils trouvent dégradantes etc
et puis de l'autre côté on a ce discours
de la police qui est quasiment en
retrait en disant non non on va pas on
va pas c'est pas pour nous c'est pas
possible nous ne voulons pas de ce
ticket et on voit ce décalage qui est si
important et qu'il ne revenait pas dans
les discours de dd policier que vous
avez vous même invité alors est-ce que
c'est lié au manque de formation qu'ils
ont reçue sur l'antiracisme les nôtres
et que peut-être d'abord avant de
d'expérimenter et 7 ce récépissé
il faudrait peut-être augmenter le
nombre de formations de nos policiers
formation à l'antiracisme formation aux
droits de l'homme formation
anthropologique est sur les cultures
c'est très important sur l'ethnie sur la
différence n'est sur les différences
ethniques sur les différentes cultures
et gestuelle parce que souvent on voit
dans le livre que monsieur pozzo di
borgo à citer mes collègues monsieur
lévy et le deuxième j'ai oublié son nom
on fait un livre sur ses contrôles un
livre scientifique ce qu'il démontre
c'est que quand même que les policières
et n'arrête pas les femmes arrêt très
peu de femmes n arrête arrête des
enfants qui ont des signes distinctifs
ethnique dessine distinctes distinctif
ethnique
il n'arrête pas les personnes âgées donc
il y a quand même chez eux et sorte de
vie mon imaginaire qu'il faut revoir et
faire un travail comportementaliste
d'abord parce qu'on peut faire le
récépissé et ben et instauré le
récépissé mais s'ils contrôlent sans
arrêt c'est vrai qu'ils vont contrôler -
parce que ça fatigue de remplir une
souche ou sinon il faut mettre le motive
c'est toujours problématique de trouver
un motif de contrôle alors bon je crois
qu'il ya aussi plein de travail à faire
un hameau
et que c'est le plus important avant
avant le récépissé
parce que n'oublions pas que c'est un
facteur majeur actuellement dans les
banlieues un facteur majeur d'énervement
et de d'incitation à l'émeute et à
l'opposition
alors voilà c'est quelques quelques
considérations qui ne vont pas changer
grand chose je suppose mais en tout cas
pour moi personnellement qui travaillent
dans les banlieues je trouve ça
essentiel et je ne me placerai pas du
côté de la police d'abord je me placerai
du côté de ceux qui elles sont
contrôlées et pour voir comment on peut
influer sur la police passion commence
par la police et excusez moi chers
collègues
si on commence par la police on se rend
en dehors d'une réalité qui est celle de
ceux qui subissent ces discriminations
merci merci madame benbassa monsieur le
comte
merci merci monsieur le défenseur des
droits pour votre rapport et votre
engagement sur sur la question moi je
souhaitais vous interrogez en liaison
avec notre actualitté légistatives et et
et la base juridique sur lequel se font
les les contrôles d'identité puisque
vous vous le signaler dans votre rapport
ils se font principalement sur la base
de l'article 78 1
mais vous êtes sous réserve des
législations spécifiques sur les
étrangers dont on aime on évoque le
sujet maintenant au sénat en particulier
pour une discussion en séance publique à
la fin de la semaine
et donc il y a le l'article l 611 1 du
ceseda qui est un produit qui quitte
aujourd'hui existe et qui pose des
possibilités de contrôle de vérification
d'identité et titre de séjour pour les
étrangers qui sont sur notre territoire
alors ce qui veut dire que pour les
interros pour les identifier pour les
contrôler il faut être assez doué pour
pouvoir déceler leur étrangeté donc
d'une certaine manière le
la différence le faciès peut être de ce
point de vue là un élément qui peut
engendrer ce type de contrôle donc à
partir du moment où nous sommes invités
à nous prononcer sur des évolutions et
l'encadrement de ce sursaut sur ce sur
ce sujet lors du projet de loi relative
à la retenue pour vérification du droit
au séjour
je voulais vous interrogez parce que il
me semble que au delà des pratiques qui
ont été évoqués dans votre rapport il ya
la base juridique la base juridique elle
doit être claire et précise pour
l'ensemble des opérateurs alors on peut
vouloir lutter contrôle contre l'autre
au faciès mais dès lors qu'on introduit
la possibilité de contrôler
spécifiquement les étrangers comment
est-ce qu'on peut arriver à lutter
contre le cos trop le faciès en
introduisant une législation ou en
conservant une législation spécifique
sur le sujet et si on conserve cette
médiation spécifiques comment l'encadrer
pour justement éviter ce contrôle au
faciès
alors quand on est quand on établit il
ya une proposition par exemple qui dit
plutôt que de mettre de nationalité
étrangère dit donc on peut déduire la
nationalité étrangère d'éléments
objectifs extrait la personne même de
l'intéressé est ce qu une telle
description de la motivation d'aller
interroger vérifier l'identité d'une
personne serait à votre avis suffisant
pour éviter le contrôle au faciès
suffisamment lisible pour les opérateurs
pour qu'ils puissent ne pas tester sa
d'une capuche ou d'un ajout d'une
couleur
comment comment est ce que vous voyez ça
est ce que vous pensez que les le au
delà des pratiques qui ont été évoqués
par vous et par mes prédécesseurs et par
les précédents d'intervenants la base
juridique doit être précisé claire est
ce que vous pensez qu'avec l'article 6
111 1 du ceseda aujourd'hui on n'a pas
quelque part une base justifiant le
contrôle au faciès qui méritaient d'être
revus et comment l'encadrer le mieux
possible et s'enlève le compte vous avez
achevé
je vous remercie monsieur le cerf merci
monsieur président
merci monsieur défenseur des droits je
nous sommes ici dans dans la volonté
donc comme vous de lutter contre un
phénomène de discrimination phénomène de
discrimination qui a ici concerne
largement donc ce contrôle au faciès
mais j'avoue que cela m'a rappelé à les
discussions au sénat lors du projet de
loi sur la création de la halde projet
de loi dont j'étais rapporteur la halde
qui est maintenant rentré dans votre
domaine de compétences où nous nous
étions longuement interrogé sur les
instruments de mesure des
discriminations
car comment lutter effectivement contre
un phénomène sans pouvoir en mesurer son
intensité et je me souviens qu'à
l'époque nous avions abordé et j'avais
abordé le problème effectivement des
statistiques ethniques
après avoir rencontré d'ailleurs par
exemple président du cran du conseil
représentatif des associations noires
qui était tout à fait d'accord pour que
l'on puisse essayer d'avancer sur ces
statistiques ethniques en matière de 2,2
d'emploi par exemple je connais dans mon
département de très grandes entreprises
dont je pense qu'il suffirait que l'on
mette noir sur blanc devant elle
la couleur de peau de leur personnel
pour qu'elles fassent un effort pour que
cette couleur se rapproche un petit peu
plus de la proportion effectivement
d'aider des personnes de couleur noire
de couleur blanche ou de couleurs
intermédiaires entre l'une et l'autre et
j'avais été violemment attaqué toute la
cordialité sénatoriales à l'époque par
deux anciens excellent collègue roger
romani et jean luc mélenchon qui ne
siège pas exactement si j'ai pas
exactement sur les mêmes bancs de
l'hémicycle mais qui m'opposait
effectivement les mêmes arguments qui
était à
le caractère universel du citoyen d'une
part et d'autre part le fait que les
problèmes que nous posions étaient des
problèmes qui serait réglé très
rapidement par les unions mixtes entre
les uns et des autres donc je me suis
demandé s'il prenait le métro aussi
souvent que moi si vous voulez parce que
c'est absolument sûr que ces problèmes
seraient de leur ont aussi rapidement
donc moi je me demande si il est
possible effectivement de d'éluder d'un
revers de main le problème des
statistiques ethniques
d'une part si réellement il n'y aurait
pas des modalités qui permettrait de les
concilier avec le respect de la
constitution
et sinon s'il n'ya pas effectivement des
modifications qui devraient être
réalisés parce que là aussi je pense que
si on avait effectivement ce type de
statistiques
il y aurait immédiatement une sorte
d'autocensure de la part des personnels
de sécurité sur les types de contrôles
auxquels ils procéderaient leur sexe une
question embarrassante mais je voulais
la poule a posé comme merci monsieur le
cerf monsieur van beirendonck eur22
remarque la première moi j'ai souvent
remarqué que les incidents les plus
notables intervenait quand la bac était
en fonctions donc j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'au sein de la police ya
véritablement un problème de doctrine
d'emploi et ça renvoie effectivement ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur plus
généralement le lien et les modalités
d'intervention entre la présence
permanente qu'on appelle police de
proximité
encore qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
voyage sous le il ya beaucoup de choses
qui voyage sous le vocable est là bas
qui est absolument nécessaire dans sa
doctrine d'intervention 1 ceci étant
c'est quand même là que les incidents à
roubaix pour parler de ce que je connais
c'est quand même là que les incidents
les plus notables interviennent et la
deuxième chose c'est que quand on fait
le défenseur des droits un rapport qui
si tu veux très clairement là le
problème on a envie de se dire aller
jusqu'au bout si je puis me permettre
et fait des préconisations sur le
contenu des formations d
des différents agents de police qui
interviennent et c'est parce que je
crois quand même que c'est
essentiellement un problème de de
contenu de la formation savez moi j'ai
réussi du temps du ministre joxe à aa
avec le sénateur diligent à obtenir
l'implantation d'une école nationale de
police à à roubaix c'est pas parce que
l'école allait dans le quartier qu'elle
s'ouvre nécessairement comme ça par
miracle ou par instantané aux
préoccupations de la vie associative du
quartier aux problèmes des jeunes et
c'est donc sans encore une fois cherché
à identifier un bouc émissaire en est
aux antipodes de cette démarche
je voudrais quand même dire que
essentiellement c'est un problème
d'acculturation au territoire de la
police de contenu de la formation et
d'un autre côté chez les jeunes de
sanctions que je réclame totalement très
forte le dé kia à un manque de politesse
de queue et c'est parce que je pense que
les droits et de word s'équilibrait mais
la formation me paraît couvrir une
partie importante du problème
merci monsieur van dirais donc monsieur
béchu merci monsieur le président
monsieur le défenseur peut-être que je
me suis trompé mais j'avais cru
comprendre que l'objectif de ce rapport
n'était pas de répondre à ceux qui
étaient dans une optique qui consistait
à penser qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures contre la police mais plutôt de
se dire que nous étions avant tout dans
un état de droit et que le statu quo en
l'état n'est pas possible il n'est pas
possible compte tenu d'un sentiment
d'humiliation
les mots ont été employés par certains
de la manière dont se déroulent les
contrôles il n'est pas possible aussi
parce que y compris du côté de la police
ça ne permet pas de restaurer ou
d'accompagner la confiance dont on a
besoin dans une institution de la
république
à partir du moment où on dit que le
statu quo n'est pas possible moi
j'entends dans les propositions vous
avez formulé un certain nombre de choses
avec force je dois dire que je suis
sensible à l'argument du droit comparé
mais dans ce cas là j'aimerais qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout
dans quelle mesure le sentiment
d'exaspération aussi d'une partie de nos
forces de police ou d'inquiétude par
rapport aux contraintes que ça leur
ferait supporter n'est pas lié à ce que
sont à l'heure actuelle les contraintes
existantes pour les autres actes de
police qu'ils exercent
autrement dit si nous comparions pas
seulement ce que générerait en termes de
travail
le récépissé le carnet à souche peu
importe la manière dont on l'appelle
avec le reste est ce qu on s'apercevrait
pas qu'il ya aussi un sentiment
d'exaspération qui peut être pas lié à
cet acte en lui même il ya une chaîne
procédurales particulièrement lourde
j'ai eu l'occasion d'autres ont
certainement fait ici d'aller passer une
nuit avec une bac une nuit avec des
gendarmes pour parler du sujet qui nous
occupe et j'ai été très frappée après
une infraction flagrante qui était d'une
simplicité confondante de voir le temps
passer à émettre et à faire les rapports
avant de pouvoir retourner sur le
terrain est pour quelque chose de banal
ne souffrent aucune contestation et qui
était extraordinairement facile entre
guillerets à appréhender à concevoir et
à relater mais le fait de devoir
apprécier sans peser la quantité d'une
marchandise saisie
le fait de devoir s'assurer que la
personne était d'accord pour ouvrir la
boîte à gants de son véhicule qui est
une extension de son domicile
le fait de on pourrait multiplier
l'ensemble des exemples ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il faut peut-être
comprendre qu'une partie de ces
événements d'exaspération n'est pas
forcément uniquement liée à l'acte en
lui même mais à ce qui se passe par
ailleurs deuxième point il serait
paradoxal que à l'issue d'une
amélioration du droit des citoyens on
finisse par renverser le contrôle
d'identité etc en quelque sorte on soit
dans une logique
consiste à ce que ce soit aux policiers
de devoir attester de son identité au
moment d'un contrôle plutôt que le
citoyen qui est contrôlé et moi
j'entends avec beaucoup de force
une partie des arguments qui ont été
évoqués sur le fait de dire que tout se
joue pas sur le terrain il se joue aussi
en amont au moment de la formation au
moment des motivations j'allais dire
d'entrer dans le corps des forces de
l'ordre je te dire que j'ai été très
sensible à un des premiers mots du
ministre sur le fait qu'il souhaitait
que le tutoiement ne soit plus de mise
parce que c'est ça peut sembler
extrêmement simple mais ça me semble sur
le plan symbolique extrêmement fort de
ce que ça dit d'une d'une égalité en
droit ou d'une égalité en dignité entre
le contrôleur et le pont et le contrôler
de ce point de vue sans préjuger de la
suite en étant sensible à l'idée des
expérimentations qui permettrait
d'éviter de rester sur des présupposés
qui serait complètement théorique
je me permettrai de de faire trois
observations terminale la première c'est
de souhaiter que si expérimentation il y
a notamment sur une base de droit
comparé on a eu jusqu'au bout pour
regarder ce que sont les pressions
administratives subi dans d'autres pays
par la police et dans quelle mesure cet
équilibre chez nous il est différent de
ce qui se passe ailleurs
la deuxième chose c'est de souhaiter que
on n'oublie pas que derrière les
contrôleurs et les contrôler il ya les
citoyens qui observent le débat et
vis-à-vis desquels les propos qui
peuvent consister à donner le sentiment
qu'il n'y aurait que des contrôles au
faciès dans notre pays n'aide pas non
plus à instaurer un climat en termes de
lien social qui soit parfait d'autant
qu'il ya beaucoup de préjugés
je précise qu'un de ses préjugés
voudrait que presque tous les policiers
soient blancs et en considérant qu'ils
fassent tous des contrôles au faciès sur
des gens de couleur la réalité n'est pas
celle là il suffit d'aller dans les
commissariats d'un sonar mérite ce pays
pour s'apercevoir que une partie de ceux
auxquels on reproche de pratiquer des
contrôles au faciès ont la même couleur
de peau que ceux qui sont contrôlés donc
que la réalité elle n'est pas aussi
simple que ça enfin et ce sera une
observation toute personnelle de ce
point de vue j'ai le sentiment que le
matricule qui ne bouleverse pas notre
aventure épique
permettrait sans combattre trois ans a
réglé la totalité de ces questions parce
qu'on est objectivement passer d'un
système où il y avait un élément
d'identification un système dans lequel
n'y en a plus aucun d'arriver à un
consensus rapide qui ne préjugerait pas
de ce que pourraient être des réflexions
plus large mais qui permettrait au moins
de se retrouver sur la fin d'un anonymat
qui à l'heure actuelle ne satisfait
personne
merci monsieur béchu monsieur gorce
oui monsieur merci monsieur le président
je le défenseur je crois que nous sommes
d'accord pour considérer que la
réflexion qui peut s'engager sur la
manière dont les contrôles d'identité
sont exercées les risques qui peuvent
représenter le point de vue d'une
discrimination
ce débat ne peut pas s'engager contre la
police mais pour la mettre en cause
on sait que ces tâches sont suffisamment
difficile pour que nous soyons pas
évidemment dans une attitude qui se veut
spontanément polémique
on a vu encore récemment les difficultés
ou qu'elle ait été confrontée dans ses
interventions
pour autant il est normal que nos
demandes à une police républicaine de
respecter les règles que le lit slater a
lui même fixé y compris dans l'intérêt
de cette police mais évidemment d'abord
chez blg dans l'intérêt du citoyen parce
que s'il ya des règles concernant le
contrôle d'identité c'est justement
parce que le fait d'exercer la force
publique pour exiger de quelqu'un qu'il
interrompt ses mouvements pour rendre
compte de certaines entités considérées
en droit et fort heureusement comme l
intervention forte qui justifie d'être
strictement encadré plus encore si elle
devait évidemment représenté une menace
par rapport à d'autres principes comme
ceux de non discrimination
comment on te dire évidemment que ce
contrôle s'effectue dans des conditions
qui nous paraissent les plus
satisfaisantes possible il y à la
rappeler le droit et les règles il faut
qu'elle soit connue
on peut évidemment souhaité qu'elle soit
mieux connu et la question de la
formation paraît centrale il ya ensuite
le climat dans lequel effectivement
l'action de ces forces de police peut
être amené à intervenir
et de ce point de vue le message que
peut passer aussi bien le parlement plus
gouvernement est d'abord le miso les
intérieurs et fondamentaux est ce qui a
été dit juste avant moi est important je
pense que miss de l'intérieur cette
manière d'ailleurs a eu raison de ne pas
intervenir spontanément et trop
directement sur la question du récépissé
dans la mesure où sans l'intervention et
ces décisions auraient nécessairement
été comprise comme une mise en cause des
services de police dont il avait la
responsabilité au moment où il venait
d'être donné
je crois que la réflexion était
nécessaire c'est le deuxième élément il
faut que au delà de cette volonté de
faire respecter le droit et de le faire
par la formation les messages qu'ils
soient passés par le mythe de la police
par les miss de l'intérieur soit des
messages qui vise à la fois a affirmé sa
confiance mais posé des conditions à
cette confiance qu'il doit en permanence
rappelé donc on est en droit d'attendre
on aura l'occasion d'en parler avec lui
sans doute qu'il renouvelle les propos
qu'il a tenus vous avez évoqué ce sur le
toit mans et tours et sur d'autres pour
rappeler qu'ils sont
les conditions dans lesquelles la police
doit intervenir mais le troisième point
celui qui me posent le plus problème sur
lequel je voulais vous vous interrogez
c'est plus au fond la question dans
lesquels des conditions dans lesquelles
on débat de ces sujets on en débat
effectivement à partir d'une émotion
public sur tel ou tel incident qui dès
lors qu'ils ont fait une somme fini par
provoquer un ensemble de réactions
mais à partir d'éléments qui sont
effectivement relativement et par vous
parler de ressenti
alors peut être qu'on peut effectivement
ne reposer que sur le ressenti difficile
de procéder à une évaluation complète
exhaustive
la question des statistiques a été posée
personnellement j'ai longtemps été
favorables à cette idée des statistiques
pour autant qu'ils soient strictement
encadrées à caractère technique dès lors
qui permet d'identifier un problème pour
autant lorsque je réfléchi aux
conséquences de ce genre de dispositif
cire de la rupture que ça un produit
dans les règles d'universalité de notre
droit des principes j'ai quand même
beaucoup de mal à finir par me ranger
même si on imagine qu'ils soient très
encadrée donc la vraie question est
celle de comment peut-on évaluer de
manière satisfaisante et régulière la
situation autrement dit je ne sais pas
si vous l'avez évoqué dans notre rapport
ne faudrait il pas imaginer ça peut être
un travail parlementaire ça peut être le
travail du défenseur des droits
un dispositif à partir des plaintes dans
bouger de saisir enfin ils ne sont que
la surface la plus négative des choses
comment imaginer un dispositif qui
permettrait de saisir des autorités
comme la vôtre comme le parlement
régulièrement de données lui permettant
de nourrir le débat parce que si on
nourrit le débat uniquement à partir
d'un événement etc on a le sentiment dès
lors qu'on a voté une loi ou rejeter un
dispositif que la question est tranchée
naturellement cole mais l'erreur
habituel et consiste à dire une fois
qu'on en a parlé qu'on a voté dans un
sens ou dans un autre
le problème ne se pose plus ce qui
évidemment le contraire de la réalité
donc comment imagines indispose
d'évaluation qui permettent de nourrir
un débat riche contradictoires en
permanence qui permettent d'orienter et
la polique gouvernement et l'attitude du
législateur c'est le président je
n'hésite pas à poser ma question parce
que je vais devoir quitter mais je
regarderai la télévision pour avoir la
réponse
moi j'ai deux deux sujets de
préoccupation j'ai fais partie des gens
qui ont voté contre le rapatriement de
la gendarmerie au ministère de
l'intérieur consiste qu'en considérant
que c'était deux métiers un peu
différent venez nous avait expliqué
clairement que le le modus operandi des
gendarmes étaient quand même différent
de celui des policiers
donc maintenant on a un bloc de
formation qui est commun donc quelles
sont vos préconisations en matière de
formation parce qu'on va arriver au
budget du ministère de l'intérieur qui
inclut celui de la gendarmerie donc
c'est peut-être le moment de faire des
propositions aux financières chiffrées
en ce qui concerne la formation
la deuxième chose on a bien conscience
de l' équilibre extrêmement précaire et
la difficulté extrême être les libertés
individuelles et puis la sécurité c'est
quand même une alchimie toujours un peu
compliqué moi je voudrais vous poser une
question qui est un peu lié au travail
que je suis en train de faire sur les
manquements dans la ferme ra c'est un
peu loin mais pas tellement en admettant
qu'on arrive à un processus dans votre
réflexion sur les fiches est sûre et sur
les identités
comment est ce que vous allez traiter
ces documents parce que le problème
n'est pas de remplir des fiches le
problème est de savoir ce qu'on en fait
parce que si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé dans la ferme erraki quand même
les faire compliqué on avait tous les
renseignements
mais on n'avait pas l'analyse donc on
admettant
qu'on arrive à régler ce problème
d'identité et de et de fiches
quels sont vos préconisations en ce qui
concerne éventuellement le traitement on
a merci merci mais tamouls et monsieur
boyer oui monsieur le président nous
avons tous conscience que notre société
disons le et est malade quand un homme
dans un immeuble et en fragilité on peut
le réparer quand une société est malade
nous avons conscience que c'est facile à
dire mais c'est difficile à trouver des
solutions
moi je voudrais monsieur le président
vous demander si vous n'avez pas
l'impression que les autorités des
gendarmes ou les agents sont un peu
désarmée et donc quand on est désarmé
on est un peu découragés ils sont
désormais par exemple quand il arrête à
un jeune il faut pas que je cible tous
sensibles et jamais un jeune qui a fait
une bêtise
aujourd'hui c'est le président c'est pas
vous que je le dirai avec les moyens de
communication par exemple les portables
quelques minutes après les gendarmes
doivent se replier doivent se taire
pensez vous pas aussi que notre société
elle est ce qu'elle est mais on tente on
fait l'analyse de du malaise que notre
société et cesser ces actes là sont
alimentés par aussi par dans un domaine
où vous avez une responsabilité
importante
les médias la télé la td qu'est ce qu'on
voit très souvent on voit où le sexe ou
la violence et je crois que c'est que
c'est très important
troisièmement monsieur le président ça
c'est pas nous qui pourront y remédier
et même avec les volontés des
gouvernements successifs y compris
suivant quand quelqu'un est désarmé
qu'il n'a pas de travail
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il ait pu that à
aller à faire des actes répréhensibles
et puis dans les conclusions j'ai pas
trouvé sur le président mais c'est
facile à dire
j'ai pas trouvé de comment je dirais de
remèdes proposés
j'ai conscience que c'est pas facile je
m'explique vous savez que les accidents
de la route ont baissé par les radars
éducatif et ou répressif
dans ce domaine là c'est différent
puisque sur la route qu'en cas les excès
de vitesse c'est du mathématiques
là c'est de l'humain c'est de
l'expression collective qui est assez
embêtante alors dans d'autres la
question sans que le président dans
d'autres pays a tant plu inverser cette
courbe
cette courbe de de ce qu'on peut appeler
des délinquances collective qui sont
veuves vraiment un très inquiétante
voilà très simplement ce que voulez vous
dire vous dire que je suis de ceux comme
tous ceux qui sont ici que nous avons
conscience que c'est un problème de
société et que dans cette société qui et
les malades c'est pas facile à trouver
une solution
merci monsieur boyer dernier orateurs
inscrits monsieur cointat bien merci
monsieur le président je me suis inscrit
un peu en retard mais enfin merci de me
donner la parole vous j'ai demandé à
apposer c'est une question parce que je
croyais qu'elle se reposait avant et
comme elle n'a pas n'a pas été je me
sens obligé de le faire
vous avez évoqué monsieur le défenseur
des droits les méthodes différence dans
la gendarmerie la police pour procéder à
des contrôles et je veux dire que
personne n'aime être contrôlé je voyage
souvent à l'étranger représentant les
français établis hors de france
il m'arrive d'être en contact avec les
autorités qui font des contrôles et je
veux dire qu'il ya certains c'est
totalement insupportable ils se croient
tout permis il vous traite comme si on
n'existait pas ou pas grand chose je
trouve ça totalement inacceptable alors
je me demande s'il n'y aurait pas
d'ailleurs peut-être une formation à
prévoir notamment par la police parce
que en général la gendarmerie n'a pas
ses difficultés c'est pareil avoir une
culture militaire une approche de
respect des uns des autres
qui fait mieux passer le message alors
du côté de la police parfois on a de
véritables cowboy et qui a un
comportement totalement insupportable
alors je ne demande s'il a urait pas une
une piste pour qu'il y ait une véritable
formation dans le contrôle car lorsque
le contrôle est bien fait quand il est
respectueux des gens ça se passe dans
général relativement bien
et c'est quand il n'y a pas ce respect
que l'on peut avoir des dérapages et des
dérapages des deux côtés des deux côtés
alors moi c'est plutôt ce message que je
transmets il faut que le contrôle et
lieu les différentes possibilités de
récépissé autres ne me choquent ni les
unes ni les autres sauf dans le cadre
d'un fichier j'estime que le contrôle
n'a rien à voir avec la constitution
d'un fichier mais à part cela je peux
accepter plus l'une ou l'autre des
propositions et je pense que celle que
retiendra davantage le défenseur des
droits de par son expérience de par ses
contacts sera certainement la plus
sensée mais il faut qu'il y ait un
contrôle qui se réalise selon des normes
parfaitement respecté par les acteurs de
ce contrôle
voilà merci merci monsieur coin cas il
ses collègues merci pour la richesse et
la diversité des approches que vous avez
présenté
monsieur le défenseur des droits merci
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour vos vos
questions et votre contribution à notre
réflexion sur ce sujet yves pozzo di
borgo
évoquant sa proposition de loi a indiqué
qu' il avait fait le choix d'une option
ou c'était un le corps d'inspection
générale
l'inspection générale des services ou
inspection générale de la police
nationale qui serait chargé de suivre
les contrôles
l'enregistrement des données anonymisées
dans votre proposition comme dans celle
de madame m bah ça le nom de la personne
contrôlée n'apparaît pas mais en
revanche figurent tous les autres devant
le lieu le motif leur etc et dans
l'hypothèse où une personne ayant été
contrôlés de manière répétitive et à ses
yeux abusive elle pourrait effectivement
se tourner vers le corps d'inspection
pour
faire prévaloir ses droits c'est une
hypothèse tout à fait recevable parce
que ils ont les effectifs et
l'équipement nécessaire pour pour
assumer cette mission
dans l'hypothèse où c'est le défenseur
des droits qu'ils veulent faire ce
serait beaucoup plus difficile pour nous
en termes d'effectifs parce que ça
serait une multiplication par 10
peut-être de notre activité au type de
la déontologie de la sécurité
secteur sur lequel je n'ai environ que
dix à douze agents pour faire face à une
multiplication par trois du nombre des
réclamations depuis la réforme puisque
auparavant la commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité ne pouvait
être saisi que par des parlementaires
aujourd'hui toute personne peut saisir
le défenseur des droits sur la question
deux ans au lieu de sécurité résultat
trois fois plus de réclamations
donc j'ai pas comment on pourrait faire
face au suivi de l'enregistrement de
données sur les contrôles donc
l'inspection générale c'est
effectivement une une hypothèse madame
benbassa oui ce qui vous a frappé dans
dans ce colloque moi aussi d'ailleurs
c'est la façon dont les policiers venus
de londres de new york d'ottawa toronto
était très de vrais avocats du
dispositif qu'ils ont mis en place
d'adam dans ces villes il faut savoir
que au moment où ces dispositifs ont été
mis en place
majoritairement les policiers dans ces
pays étaient hostiles à la mise en place
de ce système est ce que nous on dirait
sont simples c'est qu'au bout de deux
trois quatre ans les policiers ont
finalement adhéré au système
ils y ont trouvé des avantages leur mode
de fonctionnement a évolué c'est à dire
qu'ils procèdent aux contrôles
d'identité avec beaucoup plus de
discernement et avec un taux
d'efficacité plus important c'est qu'ils
étaient très frappant dans tous ces pays
où on délivre un document le nombre de
contrôles diminue mais en même temps
l'efficacité du contrôle augmente c'est
à dire sur dix personnes contrôlées
le pourcentage à la part des contrôles
qui effectivement donne lieu ensuite à
des procédures ou à des poursuites est
beaucoup plus élevé donc ça signifie que
le policier contrôle - mais qu' il le
fait à vente avec davantage de
discernement et que par conséquent en
terme de sécurité publique
il n'y a pas un abaissement de la
qualité du service rendu par les par les
fonctionnaires alors vous dites vous ce
qui m'a frappé c'est la différence entre
les policiers français qui sont très
hostiles à tout ça et les policiers
étrangers qui défend des leurs systèmes
mais je crois que les policiers
étrangers au départ n'en voulait pas
trop c'est le pouvoir politique qui l'a
décidé ils sont rentrés dans le
dispositif et et maintenant on sent que
ils en sont fiers et qu'il qui le
défendent ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant
quand même pendant le colloque c'est que
pendant toute la journée il ya eu des
policiers français syndicats direction
générale de la police
membre du cabinet du ministre des
gendarmes qui pendant toute la journée
on assister à la restitution de ces
expériences je pensais que c'était une
pédagogie qui était intéressante
vous avez parlé de la question de la
formation d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'intervenants ont évoqué la question de
la formation
effectivement c'est une question clé je
crois que le mont formation et celui qui
était le prononcer le plus souvent
autour de ce tour de table
alors je ne sous estime pas du tout la
question est d'ailleurs la conclusion du
rapport porte sur la question de
formation
alors évidemment mais je pouvais pas y
consacrer l'essentiel du rapport parce
qu'après on aurait accusé de contourner
la difficulté ou le problème mais j'ai
terminé là dessus et ça pourra faire
l'objet d'autres travaux d'autres
échanges je pense qu'il ya
un gros efforts à faire dans ce domaine
et d'ailleurs les syndicats de policiers
que nous avons vu en conviennent
parfaitement
la question de monsieur le comte je veux
s'ils voulaient bien que ce soit les
chaires senghor qui kivu répandent sur
cette question sur le motif de contrôle
peut-être d'un monsieur le sénateur en
effet ne vont pas examiner les
dispositions spécifiques aux étrangers
que ce soit dans le code des étrangers
ou les contrôles schengen et c'est dans
la mesure où en réalité la problématique
telle qu'elle est arrivée n'est pas sur
la question de la has et moi
l'expression chasse aux étrangers débat
qui était devenue il ya déjà de
nombreuses années on accusait les forces
de police de multiplier les contrôles
autour des foyers travailleurs migrants
etc
on n'est pas dans cette problématique je
dirais français versus étrangers quand
bien même ces dispositifs
peut-être produisent une forme de deux
contrôles au faciès nous voisins
espagnols sont dans cette logique et les
travaux de fuenlabrada vise bien à
dissocier les personnes contrôlées selon
leur nationalité
ici je crois que madame benbassa
l'alliance tout à l'heure la demande qui
remonte c'est bien celle de jeunes
quelle que soit leur origine qu'ils sont
français et qui contestent le fait dans
le cadre du droit commun précisément de
faire l'objet de sur contrôle et quand
on regarde l'article 78-2 du code de
procédure pénale son dernier alinéa le
set voit bien que aujourd'hui un soutien
de police peu pour tout motif et en
toutes circonstances je crois que c'est
depuis 93 qui est une disposition qui a
peu évolué et validé par le conséquence
yonne au demeurant ou en réalité il va
besoin d'avoir deux motifs
particulièrement signalés pour pouvoir
procéder à ce contrôle
donc c'est bien une question de droit
commun qui est enfin le lac est le
questionnement est arrivé sur le terrain
du droit commun et en quel que soit le
droit commun permet tellement de
contrôles que ne vont pas ne sommes pas
intéressés à ces contrôles spécifiques
qui viennent sans doute renforcer le
phénomène mais qui ne sont en tout cas
pas la cause je crois la question
monsieur le cerf sur les statistiques
ethniques
bon alors c'est un vaste débat donc on
peut évoquer à propos des contrôles
d'identité aux à propos de beaucoup
d'autres questions
cet exercice de réflexion et d'études
j'ai voulu le faire à droit constant or
si on voulait introduire des dispositifs
permettant de mesurer le nombre de
personnes contrôlées en fonction de leur
origine on n'est pas du tout dans le
droit constant et au rayon se heurte aux
dispositions constitutionnelles
le conseil constitutionnel décision de
novembre 2007
si les traitements nécessaires à la
conduite d'études sur la mesure de la
diversité des origines des personnes de
la discrimination et de l'intégration
peuvent porter sur des données objectif
ils ne sauraient sans méconnaître le
principe énoncé par l'article 1er de la
constitution reposer sur l'origine
ethnique ou la race
alors c'est un débat
qui peut avoir toute sa légitimité mais
je ne voulais pas inscrire cet exercice
de réflexion et d'études dans un cadre
juridique qui n'est pas le nôtre
on aurait pu me le reprocher j'ai voulu
raisonner à droit constant
c'est un sujet effectivement intéressant
mais bon mesurez bien pour avoir
réfléchi sur ces questions qu'ils
ouvrent voilà sur des perspectives qui
sont quand même radicalement contraire à
nos principes constitutionnels
ils sont pas intangibles mais moi ils me
partient pas de dire qu'il faut revoir
la constitution gérer vraiment résonner
dans le cas de nos institutions et de
notre pratique le public m
dominique baudis le défenseur des droits
était donc auditionné hier par la
commission des lois sur son un rapport
relatif aux relations police citoyens et
aux contrôles d'identité à suivre sur
public sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit le
sénateur communiste de paris pierre
laurent et puis à 18h30 et à 22h02
édition spéciale consacrée aux élections
américaines et à la réélection de barack
obama est très bonne journée à tous sur
public sénat